bonjour encore une vidéo courte et
informatif sur cette chaîne mais ne vous
inquiétez pas je viens de tourner un
épisode de jean todt a bad ass qui
sortira dès que j'aurai montée c'est à
dire sous peu si je publie cette vidéo
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous dire que ça
y est mon livre sort en librairie demain
et cette fois je peux même vous montrer
puisque j'en ai reçu un exemplaire et
j'ai pu le lire en exclusivité et il me
l'écrire en exclusivité bref comme vous
pouvez le voir il est composé d'une
jolie couverture avec ma tête dessus de
diverses pages jeu très douce au toucher
avec de jolies images
tadam et surtout de série de caractères
composants des mots qui vous apprendront
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur l'hygiène les superstitions
l'alimentation au moyen-âge
bref la vie quotidienne au moyen-âge et
ça tombe bien parce que c'est le titre
du livre vous pourrez le trouver dans
toutes les bonnes librairies dès demain
je mettrai aussi quelques liens en
descriptions et aussi n'hésitez pas
allez chez votre petit libraire du coin
pour demander s'ils l'ont parce que du
coup ça permet de faire connaître de
livrer éventuellement de leur donner
envie d'en commander quelques uns pour
leur vie brève et donc ça fait plaisir
voilà merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt pour une vidéo un peu plus
historique c'est mon livre
or aux barres